[Music]
there they come right
there
Ready's
[Music]
TR you don't need no baggage you just
get
on
all you need is Faith
[Music]
to you don't need
ticket just
[Music]
the what's going
on what's going on huh you little
cinnamon dick tips what y'all up to
huh you little oyster pervert
huh you out there playing with your seat
shells aren't you aren't you you out
there playing with your seashells aren't
you huh people get
ready that's it that's the Blind Boys of
Alabama right there people get
ready people get
ready for the
train blind boy of Alabama man you got
to check them out if you haven't I mean
the title of them says it enough man
Blind
Boys so that's men no sight in their
eyes uh of Alabama man so the simple
fact that that they're a blind man even
doing well in Alabama that's beautiful
make an amazing music man they got a
choir they travel everywhere I not a
choir they're a group you know they're
um they make albums
dude they make
albums what's up guys it's uh it is
actually it's 4:15 in the morning it is
uh Monday January
30th
2017s and this is this past weekend I am
in Virginia
Beach and it's cold man it's been cold
here can't even get outside can't even
get my feelings you know cuz that
coldness
just like right when you right when you
get outside that coldness for me starts
in my neck that coldness gets in my neck
and
just then it creeps up like right back
behind my
jawline and kind of just gets like
starts to Slither inside of my ears and
that's where the coldness starts to get
me and then I start to feel I I feel
defeated quickly I would not surviving
the elements man I would not if there
were a plane crash I better crash in
Cancun you know maybe
CA uh Brazil I could do a plane crash
from Brazil you know a
child um but yeah if I crashed in the
Arctic dude I
would I would perish bro I would perish
you know in fact if I even I might start
packing a little headstone in my travel
bag that's not a bad idea um that
wouldn't be bad for a airport gift shop
item get your little headstone that
would survive any type of um predicament
crash
drown uh you know light fire cuz it's
going to be expensive to get one that
could really survive a heavy fire um
extremely F flame retardant stuff is
pretty
expensive so but yeah get you something
that could survive some light uh
catastrophe and get your little
headstone shop and uh cuz some people
some people that's all you want you know
you just want to make it easy on your
loved ones when you pass away some of us
that's all that's our only we don't want
to call us too much of a Ruckus you know
we just want to make it easy uh that way
you you you're right there you crash
somebody survives or they find you boom
pop The Headstone out of it I'm sure it
comes in like a special little case you
know you know uh just headstones to go
maybe you know like a little duffel
maybe it comes in a
duffel and you just plop it in the
ground right there you know here lies
your boy you can fill it in it's kind of
like a Mad Libs headstone so that way
you get a realistic epit uh Epitaph you
get a realistic epot you know here lies
fill in the blank you know
know
um he was survived by blank that way if
you got some children wife uh
cats uh Karma if you got bad karma
looking for you you know cuz don't think
when you die that your
karma your karma is still out there and
that's another thing people aren't
thinking about when they die if you're
leaving Bad Karma then you that that
that [__] is swirling it's going to get
somebody you know it's going to get your
friend uh your nephew um animals you
might have uh you know others it's going
to get
somebody what's going on baby boy huh
you little
freaking you little muffin sniffing
gypsies huh you guys good
huh huh you stand off that dust huh
that's what I'm hoping for that's what
I'm hoping for let me check my levels
okay we got audio we're pretty good here
I'm in uh Virginia Beach man if you
haven't been here it's a cool place a
lot of military uh tonight we had
lesbians get in free night at the comedy
um at the Funny Bone Comedy Club here in
Virginia Beach I want to thank everybody
that came out and it was it was some
great shows beautiful audiences just
good natured people I mean just good
natured you know people that just know
how to hug people that know how to hug
that's what they should have a damn
test you know they're banning people or
there's you know they're keeping people
out of out of the country um just give a
damn hug test you want to you want some
border security you put a big you put a
breasty a girthy
just you know just a a a uh just a just
thick in the card of vascular
area Urban
woman or grandparents white lady too out
there by the uh border and you have them
hug whoever's coming in cuz if you want
a crystal ball you want a crystal ball
of people's
feelings you hug a you hug a sweet thick
sister huh you hug one of them big
little cinnamon bears and they will know
they will know if you are a good person
or not they know where your heart is at
cuz a thick sister she you know a
rubenesque just chesty just you know
Ela El torsa the
chest those women they are they are just
an emotional crystal ball you know they
crystal ball till you fall dude they can
predict what's going
on cuz sometimes you hug somebody and
you're like this [__] is squirly
you know he don't have have anything in
his rib cage he don't have anything
within his bones there's no bone density
there's no trust in this person there's
no there's no honor there's no
commitment you know there's no
loyality so I think that would help that
would be something good for the Border
man uh or any border anywhere you
know uh we just you know that'd be good
anyway what are we talking about
Virginia Beach Virginia Beach yeah great
audiences this week week um great
audiences man just fun you know uh and
we had lesbians come in free Sunday
night that's my new thing so if you are
in any of these upcoming cities actually
I'll drop these dates on you right now
uh February 2nd through
the 5th 2 third and fourth next weekend
I'll be or this weekend actually I'll be
in shamberg Illinois it's outside of
Chicago um at the Chicago improv the
following weekend I'll be in Baltimore
or tonium Maryland at uh mey's Comedy
Club never been there um and the weekend
after that I'll be in La Hoya that is
February 17th and 18th La Hoya
California uh and the weekend after that
I'll be uh February 22nd through 26th
I'll be in Denver at The Comedy Works
South comedy work South so if you want
to come out um come on out those are the
dates those are the
dates but yeah [__] dang what was I
talking about man what was I talking
about uh I don't know see that's a
problem I got to get a sidekick look I
know a lot of people are like when you
going to get a sidekick you know your
Sidekick game is weak I know I got to
get a sidekick I'm considering I'm
considering you know we just got to see
what'll happen it's hard man you know
it's hard you know things are tough but
onward so I'm in Virginia
Beach great shows beautiful people came
out oh I was saying so if you are in one
of those cities I just mentioned and
you're a lesbian a lady that loves the
attention of uh the heartfelt attention
and emotional and sensual attention of
other women then Sunday night you get
him free to my show the password is LOL
gbt um you can use that to get in Lick
City some people want to drop Lick City
as the alternate if you you know want to
be fun that's a another so those are the
pass words get in um tell your lesbian
friends uh lesbians come out cuz my
father and people say well Theo what do
you you know what's the cause you know
why you what's why you want extra
lesbians at the show why are you
reaching out to
lesbians um and I'll tell you this my
father I didn't know my father very well
you know my father I talked about this
before was very old my father was born
in
1910 um he was a missionary from
Nicaragua I'm polish Nicaragua aguan one
of the few maybe the last bro the last
polish Nicaraguan bro where my PO
Nicks
ho and uh and he always told me I had
the heart of a
lesbian my father always told me that
when I was
young uh he said I was a Survivor and
that I had the heart of a lesbian and uh
that always resonated with me man and I
always would resonate I felt this Reverb
coming off of lesbians that I met
one time I called uh my mother won a
perm on the radio
once um she did she won a perm on the
radio once she wanted outright so there
was some contention but she wanted
outright and uh and a couple beautiful
lesbians brought that furniture brought
that uh oh she want a perm so then they
had this they had this commercial on
television for this man big Charlie he
was selling chairs um Big Charlie's
chairs you already knew that Big
Charlie's chairs big he's selling chairs
seat areas places you could put your you
know lower half of your body if you
don't want to stand up you get the drill
you know what they are um you know just
like individual
benches so big Charlie after my mom won
that perm she got that perm boy and I
mean
huh I don't if you remember the first
time you saw and my we didn't think we
could get a per like perm was for people
that had them a little bit of
money okay we got some money poy you
know we got some dineros in the uh in
the uh in
Theos you know so we didn't think we
could get a perm so when my mom won that
perm we're fired up you know we're keyed
up on happiness you know I mean when she
got home with that perm boy looked like
somebody just deep fried my mother just
deep fried in my mother's head for about
9 seconds beautiful
just that hang time this no hang time
coming off the back just tight just
tight
tight that thing boy just you could you
could just you could lick the bottom of
that perm and cut your tongue that's how
clean it
was now at the time they had a
commercial on television for Big
Charlie's chairs this man big Charlie
selling you already know at furniture
man I told you that so I called up big
Charlie because they said on the
furniture on the uher uh on the
commercial that he would bring the chair
to your home and show you how
comfortable the chair was so I ring a
ling a
ling big Charlie somebody answered I
think maybe a Vietnamese lady or
something or maybe somebody somebody and
they said big Charlie be there four to 6
weeks to show that chair but my goal was
to actually set big Charlie up with my
mother CU big Charlie seemed like a hard
worker this man on the commercial my
mother's a hard worker you know
delivered newspaper since I was born so
I'm figuring I'm going to set them up so
I called Big Charlie somebody answers
the phone they said big Charlie be there
four weeks six weeks anyway fast forward
few weeks my sister yells up somebody's
at the door I come running down
open the door no B NBC baby no big
Charlie but two adult lesbians standing
right there beautiful ladies
um and I just I remember just right when
I looked
at at this the more jacked one you know
the daddy the bull or whatever you know
whatever they call them the hero you
know the uh the big spoon or whatever
they whatever the terminology is you
know the one who kind of looked like she
probably had like a you know like you
know like her
cliturus you know like her clur would be
in a neck brace you know what I'm saying
bro you know what I'm saying the kind of
girl who's like who vagina know how a
thumb thumb wrestle you know what I'm
saying she and I just I locked eyes with
that woman cuz big Charlie didn't come
to show the furniture that was a rude
you know that was um snake oil salesman
they were bullshitting you they were
bullshitting big Charlie wasn't going to
show up and I didn't know that at the
time you know I still believed in big
business you
know but what it happened
was me and this lesbian lady we locked
eyes they came to show the furniture and
um and I just knew from that moment
on I think kind of what my father was
talking about that I had the heart of a
lesbian that I had that I had just had
that Vigor in me you know that Vigor
that at certain times of my life I was
going to be against odds and uh and that
I was going to survive and I was going
to you know
just that that life was going to be a
hustle and I was going to be emotional
and I was going to be uh and I was going
to be confused but caring and just all
those things man so and then now
ironically I got this adult haircut
where a lot of lesbians cuz I have an
adult haircut now a lot of lesbians will
approach me about this haircut um cuz I
got some I got this solid you know I got
that Lord's favor in the back you can
see it if you're on YouTube you can
check out the YouTube channel and and
see this uh cuz I record straight onto
the video on YouTube for at least half
of the show because the file gets too
big but you can see I got that little
bit of the Lord's favor coming off the
back of this new hairstyle
anyhow so what were we talking about
dude I'm in Virginia Beach beautiful
night I want to thank the lovely ladies
that came out I want to thank everybody
that came out gay straight uh confused
out there
pets pet owner only no human emotions
everybody that came out you know um
everybody's always welcome uh in My Walk
of Life uh and we had all types of
people man and it was great dude very
diverse City here very diverse City uh
what else dude uh last time I was here
so I told this story on stage last time
I was in Virginia Beach dude and it's a
great black white area if you want to
see black and white people um you know
cuz there's a lot of places where where
a lot of black and white people still
don't get along well or there's just not
a ton of mixing I don't want to say
integration because legally there is but
but to be honest you go to most a lot of
cities then you know black people hang
out here white people hang out here you
know it's starting to get a lot more
diverse uh in places but like Atlanta
like Atlanta's the future you know city
of you know you see a lot of black
wealth and you see and it's amazing you
see like a lot of um it's just it's a
city that's been Exemplar Exemplar
exemplary in my lifetime of uh of
progress for sure but you also see that
here you see a lot of um you just see a
lot of just interracial getting along
you know and it's it's good to see with
all the with the the media constantly
telling us that nobody can get you know
like showing all these fights and people
and all this [__] it's great to see
that there are cities out there and
environments where if you just go and
you put put your heartbeat out there
then uh it's going to reverb off of some
other people you're going to see what's
going on you know you throw your eyes
over on somebody if you just put your
sight in your hand and just hum it at
some in some direction into a new place
then you can see uh you know you'll see
and this is one of those places man here
in um Virginia Beach so very diverse we
had some great crowds came out so last
time I'm here I'm driving by this
McDonald's right they had a snowstorm
last time I was here and and I'm you
know like I was saying in the beginning
like if I'm in a plane crash dude I'm
not going to survive in the snow you
know I'm going have to crash at a beach
I'm going have to crash at a resort okay
like if we're crashing I'm going to be
like can we crash uh by the club
M that's coffee I'm drinking baby that's
that baby that's that just brackish
that's that brackish caffeine Daddy's
trying to get that
you know what I'm saying I'm trying to
pet my
insides you know what I'm saying I'm
trying to pet my insides with some
energy that's why I'm on that coffee so
anyhow onward we had
um yeah I I wouldn't survive in the
elements you know like if I was in like
that movie alive they have that movie
alive where you have to eat somebody if
you when the plane crashes um I couldn't
I don't I they would I'd be the one You'
probably get eaten and if I had to eaten
somebody I might have talked about this
before but but I would have Vietnamese
person you know I know that uh I think I
mentioned before that I don't think I
could be a cannibal but but I was at a
Best Buy once in I considered eating a
Vietnamese man beautiful little man
beautiful
um th Thum or thumb maybe what might
have been his name like you know like a
two of your 10 thumb but without the be
THM um anyhow so last time I'm here at
Virginia Beach I'm at a stoplight
brother gets in my car man a brother an
adult brother uh gets just gets into the
back seat of my
car right and goes where we
going
dude and let me tell you I
said wherever you want to go that's what
I said man and I could tell in his voice
he didn't seem like it was freezing
outside so he didn't seem like he was
you know up for any trouble or anything
like that uh but then he he's like okay
and he just rattled off a place an area
over in Portsmith uh and I drove him
over there and that's a just a close
area here to where I am near Virginia
Beach but that's called suddenly Uber
that's when you are suddenly Uber and if
you don't think you could Uber Drive
wait till somebody gets in the back of
your car and just says where we going
look you will drive them where they want
to go so suddenly Uber man suddenly Uber
that's the new thing I guess it was last
time I was
here oh man what else I'm tired dude I'm
so tired I can't even tell you what are
y'all doing today y'all going to work
what are you guys up to um what are you
guys up to let me think about what your
life might be right right like right now
you got
um you got you probably maybe you're
heading to work it's Monday maybe you an
electrician you know that's Brave dude
what I'm going to take a chance at
getting electrocuted every day just so
people could have cable and their
blenders can work and [__] that's ballsy
dude that is
ballsy uh plumber that's another
gangster job bro you know what I'm
saying straight up just showing up and
just being a [__] Jacker by somebody
else's house dude that's crazy right
that's ballsy man think of some other
jobs uh tree climber my brother used to
climb trees he did he climbed trees for
a while and he cut uh dude he saw he had
a chain saww he was up in the tree and
he sawed right into a I'm going give you
a chance to guess it three he saw it
into a 3 2 one
beehive and this was was he was like in
one of those climbing things where you
just kind of like scoot up the thing
with like a big rubber band kind of like
you used to see on the cartoons cuz cuz
they still do that it's probably about
nine years ago and uh and he sawed into
a beehive inside of the tree it was one
of those interior ones like one of the
Mansions you know just like a damn
little honey Mansion you know just that
straight up uh that nectar Vector
bro so we saw it into one and then had
like through the chainsaw bees attacking
him and just said he was running through
people's backyards until uh until I
think he either jumped in a swimming
pool or ran into somebody's house but
that's some G [__] bro so that's how my
brother can handle stuff really well
these days he's very good at handling uh
you know the bees that life throws at
him you know in a weird way he he just
he would be like a good um Mission
Control in a in a beehive which I don't
know if that's a real thing but like you
know the the person who is like okay we
need this be coming in here and this be
coming in here and this B my brother's
good at that kind of stuff just um
thinking clearly uh making decisions
pretty quick anyhow man what the [__] am
I even talking about dude God I don't
know
um I'll give you a sensual report
sensual report
uh still staying off the pornography let
me check my app I got a app on my phone
it tell me when the last time I looked
at any porn ography was um had a
instance this weekend though this
girl uh not my type of G she wasn't my
type
um she threat she's like threaten to
give me a [__] like literally follow
me to my hotel and then threaten to give
me a blow job dude who does that she's
like oh you don't think I'll suck your
dick and I'm like what
uh just hoping you won't 54 days I just
saw boom 54 days off of
pornography um 54 days off of
pornography I'm two days clear on
masturbation for now so you know got a
little lonely in these hotel rooms
you're getting a little Lonesome um so I
was just really monitoring myself you
know basically just being sensual I had
some sensual thoughts and I just acted
on them you know why I'm acting on my
own sensual
thoughts uh but yeah defend that girl
who threatens to blow somebody oh really
I fine that I'll suck your dick like
come on lady like you know so that was
you know I had to say you know obviously
no I was like no but I had to I mean
this lady was just a you know an
aggressive five and a half you know and
not that that really matters the looks
of it but it was just no attraction I
don't like somebody threatened suck my
dick it's dangerous dude you know you
want to discuss it you want to draw a
picture and be like yes or no like a
picture of a mouth and like maybe a
sketch of what you think my penis might
look like and then put a check yes or no
box that's a possibility you know but
when you're just threatening to blow
somebody okay I'm not going to put my
penis into somebody's mouth that I
barely know who's been threatening me
with that same mouth that's crazy dude
that's like my brother climbing back up
that tree knowing the bees are there and
just cutting right back in that's crazy
what else
man um the sensuality other time I got
to really offer some heavy sensuality
where I'll tell you this one time I was
in Pittsburgh Pennsylvania Pittsburgh
beautiful place I caught pink eye and
Pittsburgh numerous
occasions uh so they had a couple hot
strands going around there and you know
this was probably late late 2000s early
2010s they had a couple of hot strands
of uh conjunctivitis in the area and I
caught some but um these two ladies had
come from uh Wheeling West Virginia down
from the
Hills uh to my comedy show in Pittsburgh
and afterwards this lady and this and
this girl is you know like a young not
Young young girl but like you know legal
legal age young lady and it was a girl
and her it was a girl and her aunt
that's who it was I'm trying to explain
their Dynamic I'm so tired uh a girl and
her aunt they offer to uh beessential
with me in this car dude I think it was
a capri who makes a capri let me look
that up really quick
Capri
vehicle I think that was a Mercury Capri
yeah that was it dude oh they're nice
huh yeah this one wasn't that nice not
as nice as you can't see the one I'm
looking at online but anyway yeah they
say you want to come and get some of
this you know and I was and I didn't
want it and I you know I I was just
trying to pretend like I was blinking a
lot but just I think when I was going
through one of those fits of pink eye
and and like you should come get some of
this Wheeling feeling that's what they
said man that Wheeling feeling you know
and that was I mean first of all the
Wheeling feeling is seems incestral out
of the gate because y'all are related
these people they're family members
these people are family members dude you
know so I don't want to be that liaison
between a aunt and a niece you know what
I'm saying like that that's that job is
for other family members who were
supposed to be doing that genetically
I'm not supposed to be sensually
Connecting the Dots here you know that's
that's outside it's going outside the
realm of of genetics you know I'm not
supposed to be that Middleman for y'all
they're supposed to be you know um a
sister and a a spouse or something you
know you know how it works family tree
anyway that was another time I got
offered some
sensuality oh God what else man I'm
trying to think
um about another time I got offered
some now I tell you this story man and
I'm going to get going because it's day
it's uh it's daytime I'm I'm going to
try to get like 45 minutes sleep before
I got to be at the airport important
because there's a bunch of protesting
going on so I'm concerned about that I
mean I get protesting that's an American
right protest all you want doing it at
the
airport that just today it's making me
upset maybe I'm being selfish but you
know I just I mean I just want to get
back to my bed um but then there's
probably people don't want to get back
to their beds too and they can't maybe
they can't I don't you know I don't know
what you know I don't know enough about
about it really to comment on it but I'm
just hoping I get home okay um the the
what was I going to talk about
God feel like I got a mouse in my head
dude sometime I really think I have like
a mouse in my head that just right when
I have a thought the Mouse runs over to
that area where the thought is and eats
that thought bro that's crazy isn't it I
mean that's irrational that's
irrational um
oh I got high at this party this is the
first time I think I ever got high on
marijuana you know I was a young I was a
Youngster
and and I go on with my brother my
brother um my brother who doesn't uh who
doesn't embibe in in uh drugs anymore
he's an adult now beautiful family he's
a beautiful brother um but at the
time we were children you know he was
maybe 15 and I was 13 he took me to a
party out there in uh rural
Illinois uh cuz my mother's from uh uh
just outside of Kiwani Illinois that's a
small small town um she's from outside
of there from Stark County Illinois so
my brother took me to this party out in
the corn fields and people was out there
and they were doing you know just
smoking cigarettes and uh drinking beer
and uh what else just doing you know
when you're that AG you smoke whatever
you know you smoke your [__] thumb
bro if somebody could put it in a
pipe so I mean you'll smoke your [__]
you'll smoke your sister's hair you know
if you cut off a couple grams of it
while she's sleeping you'll cook up a
little bit you you'll cook up a [__]
young ladies braid you know you you [__]
I'll smoke a braid bro I'll smoke a
braid so I get high with these people
out in this corn field there's a party
and people are drinking it's just like
the party you would always think about
like in a corn F there's like a tractor
in the distance and there's just people
just drunk and just being dumb and just
being young well all night I thought it
was kind of wild if I went over and
urinated they had a man who parked a car
a Ford Escort and I always loved a Ford
Escort man we had a few escorts in our
family you know my mother came in with
some money once and bought an escort and
my first car was actually a Ford Escort
years later no front uh no front
passenger seat in my car um they said
they were going to give it to me later
they never sent it after I bought the
car used for $800 and they supposed to
sent that seat so my car was if you got
in the front passenger seat you just had
to walk through to the back seat but
anyway so all night I keep sneaking over
to this Ford Escort and I was urinating
into the back seat I just opened the
door and just urinating this dude's back
seat man I'm not proud of it I was just
you know being young and dumb and so all
night man I I was drinking beers and I
was young I could drink a lot of beers
and just drink them and just urinate
them out you know I was just basically a
uh a conduit for this Lor this this
beverage so I'm urinating in this
backseat all night well eventually some
people some people everybody started
leaving the party or whatever and I
needed to ride home and everybody else
had already loaded up and the only
person who offered to take me home this
dude didn't know I'd been urinating in
his back seat all this whole time the
only dude who offered to take me home
was that
dude and somebody called shotgun so here
I am riding in a just
soaked back seat man just a urinated
just bench you know just a cushiony
bench in the back of a car you know what
a back seat is and um and here I am dude
and that was just a crazy time so that
was a little bit of that Wheeling
feeling I guess when you're riding in
your own urine you know that's probably
similar to you know being in a threesome
with your aunt that's that Wheeling
feeling I bet but I didn't want it I
didn't want it in Pittsburgh I didn't
get it and uh I guess I just you know I
just that's Karma right there that's
piss Karma bro that's piss Karma so you
know that what else man that's about it
dude you know I just want to thank
everybody who's supporting the podcast
if you have any ideas or thoughts on how
to make it better let me know you know
look I don't know what I'm doing okay
honestly I'll be honest I didn't even
want to get up right now and do this
dude you know I didn't want to but um
but you guys have been supportive man
people have been you know chiming in and
saying if they like this or don't like
this um I'm trying not to talk politics
sometimes it's hard it's a it's a
riveting time um I'm trying to see
things from other people's perspective
uh you know I'm just trying man you know
I mean that's a personal update if you
want that I'm just still I'm trying to
be a decent person man it's hard you
know it's hard I want to be selfish I
want to you know get caught up in my
feelings my brain gets angry at me um
you know I I get negative thoughts I
feel low
selfworth um I feel less than you know
and I'm battling those things every day
uh but I'm trying man you
know I just try and take action that's
my big thing right now if I get caught
thinking negatively I get moving move my
feet get out the bed you know go find
you a little uh water a plant phone a
friend you know listen to some music to
the Beach Boys maybe listen to The Beach
Boys or some
Nelly you know get your heart going you
know call somebody tell them you love
them you know draw a picture of
something draw a picture of something
you can draw decently don't sit there
trying to draw something you can't
[__] draw that will depress you dude
I can draw roosters I can draw the front
of cars those are two things I'm pretty
good at drawing and um what else that's
about it I think so I have to look back
at some of my old art books but it's
mostly just pictures of those two things
um all right man so that's it dude those
are the upcoming dates you know that we
got next week I'll be uh in outside of
Chicago uh shamberg improv then I'll be
at uh in Baltimore muoy and then I'll be
at the La Hoya comedy store in La Hoya
and then I'll be at Comedy Works Denver
you can get some BR shirts if you like
the BR shirts man I got some cool new
stuff coming out I got a new uh album
that's popping out really soon just
can't really bring it up too much yet so
I'm excited about that um and I just
want to thank my boy Joey Coco Diaz uh
for being so supportive I want to give
congratulations uh to uh Coco's the best
man I got to say that the dude calls me
and I talked to him the other day I told
him I wasn't feeling very well and he
gave me a call the next day just a check
on me you know it's just nice you don't
see a lot of that in this business you
know a lot of people out for themselves
in this Hollywood business don't believe
all the hype you see these people all
romanticizing each other on
television but the truth is they're only
romantic when uh when they're all in the
same Financial bed you know so um
outside of the sheets people fending for
themselves mostly but it was nice to see
Joey Diaz give me a nice call uh Frank
Castillo there's a show on on television
called the roast battle uh Frank
Castillo won it young comedian really
great and if you are traveling dude out
to Los Angeles stop into the world
famous comedy store that place man it
rocks dude it really really really rocks
so that's it man I'm theovon you can
follow me anywhere at theovon t h e o v
o n um if you want to grab some dope
underwear uh they're not a sponsor of
mine but I wear them all the time
they're a sponsor of my other podcast
allegedly that's a Hollywood podcast uh
it's meundies meundies.com
theoo they got beautiful draws bro see
if I got any on right now I do actually
look at these
bro camo for your whmo camo for youro uh
so anyway you can get those man 20% off
good deal right there uh anyhow man I
love you guys have a good week you know
and uh and I'm going to try to keep my
spirits up why don't you do the same
let's meet back here next week week and
if you have any thoughts or feelings man
let me know anything you want me to
answer talk about hit me up I didn't get
any requests this week but that's okay
uh I got some support by you guys
listening so so have a great Monday man
hug somebody call your mother tell you
love her even if you don't just pretend
for the day and see if that uh see if
that love grows a little bit so next
time you might actually even maybe you
love her a little bit more you know um
do your best you know call your sister
dude everybody's sister needs a hug
needs a call man um you guys be good man
this is this past weekend um January
30th it is almost 5:00 a.m. sweet Christ
dude man that Wheeling feeling boy let's
play this out of here with my boys huh
these are blind men can you imagine that
being blind bro being blind and getting
the job
done you know what I'm saying I can see
dude and I can't
sing
so now they just they can't even see
[Music]
bro don't need ticket you just
alone people
[Music]
get beautiful
song that's what I hope it's like when
you go to heaven
[Music]
man you hear that faith is the key man
have some Faith you
know Heaven Ain't just for Christians
man Heaven's for everybody dude heaven's
just a Depot man it's train
depot you just keep your heart good and
then and when you pass from here man you
just standing at that train station and
that train come and pick you up boy man
you get on that train boy I bet it's
beautiful on
there they probably got Little Koala
bears serving you
cocktails they probably got probably got
nice
snakes can you imagine that nice
[Music]
and every blind person can sing
man that's who's on that
train and it don't even run on cold man
that train that
train that train runs on just just good
feelings man
hugs the more people hug the faster that
train
goes and you could just look out the
window and
just you can just see all the good parts
of your life that
is they flash right before your eyes
every time you look out the window so
you could always have your life right
there with
you that'd be nice huh
man and you get to see the people you
love some of them are on the train some
of them still out of the window you
know that train man it's nice bro
they got a smoking car where you could
smoke a cigarette if you want
to you could have a little cigarette you
know in a dancing car you could learn to
dance
man case you don't know how to dance you
could still learn even though you dead
man that's magic man that's what I want
Man People Get
Ready that's the Blind Boys of Alabama
man
that's the Blind Boys of
Alabama
blind still gifting
us you know not to say that they
couldn't but just to be brave enough to
sing when you can't even see that's
beautiful man that's pretty beautiful
you guys have a good day man peace